Due to backwards compatibility C++
will neverbecome any simpler.
But the way that we use it can.
Welcome back everyone.
I'm James Murphy.
And todaywe're talking about the
simplest smart pointer in C++
Unique Pointer `std::unique_ptr`
This is a dumb pointer
otherwise known as a raw
pointer or just a pointer.
But this is a smart pointer.
So what makes it sosmart?
Smart pointers are just wrappers
around regular old pointers
that help you prevent very
common bugs.
Namely, forgetting to delete a pointer
and causing a memory leak
or accidentallydeleting a pointer
twice or in the wrong way.
They can be used in a similar
way to normalpointers.
And they automate away some of the manual
process causing some of the most commonbugs.
Let's take a look at a
specific example.
We have a vector
of pointers to widgets
where eachwidget is allocated
on the Heap using `new`.
We're using a vector of pointers
instead of a vectorof actual widgets
because we're imagining there might
be some kind of inheritance hierarchygoing on.
In actuality, we just have
a single widget class.
It just stores an integer and prints
something on construction or destruction.
Let's also suppose we've already written
code using rawpointers or raw references.
In this case we're just printing
something from the widget.
Getting backto our example.
We have a pretty typical workflow.
We create our vector and push
five widgets onto it.
Then we loop over them and
do some work.
Maybe the user closes a widget.
So we pop that one off anddelete it.
Or maybe we peel some of the widgets off
and do some different work with it.
Once we'redone with that
one we delete it.
At the end we loop over the vector and
delete all the remainingwidgets.
This code works but it is
very very error prone.
Let's take a look at just a few of the ways
this could have gone wrong.
First we're calling new in a loop.
If the first new succeeds but
thesecond one throws an exception,
then we just leap the first one.
To handle that case without
smart pointers,
you'd need something like
a try-except and or go to fail.
No real issues justlooping through
and using the widgets though.
But in this case, say a widget is closed,
it's very easy to forget to delete it.
This is one of the most common
ways that memoryis leaked.
Most likely nothing will go wrong with
your program if you forget to delete this pointer.
You've just got a very very
tiny memory leak.
This case is even easier to forget because
the deletehas to be after the use.
And of course, if all the widgets are closed, it's
very easy to forget todelete all of them.
Or instead of forgetting to delete the widget,
you might forget to pop thewidget.
In which case, you'll accidentally delete it a
second time when you loop through the vectorat the end.
Deleting a pointer twice is
undefined behavior.
So if you do this even once on
accidentanywhere in your program,
the entire program is undefined.
This could result in a segvault,
garbage data being displayed
to your user
or worse a silent wrong answer
in a calculation.
Theidea behind smartpointers is to
make ownership of the pointer explicit.
An owner of a pointer is anobject
that's responsible for deleting the pointer.
So a unique pointer models an object
thathas exactly one owner at any given time.
You could transfer or give
up ownership.
But whena unique pointer is destroyed,
it's responsible for deleting whatever it owns.
This completely getsrid of any confusion about
when where or who's in charge of deleting a pointer.
The way we cleanup this example
is by using a vector of unique pointers
instead of a vector of raw pointers.
So, here we're using a unique pointer
to widget instead of a pointer to widget.
Here you can pushback unique
pointers instead of raw pointers.
You can construct a unique
pointer yourself passingin a new widget.
But for reasons beyond the
scope of this video,
the factory function make
uniqueis a better alternative.
All make unique does is make
a unique pointer
by calling new widget andforwarding all
the arguments that you passed in.
For type safety reasons unique pointer will not
automatically convert to a function expecting apointer.
Instead you can use the get function to
access the underlying pointer.
Alternatively if the code that you've
already written was usingreferences,
the dereference operator works
with smart pointers.
Dereferencing the smart pointer
willdereference its underlying pointer.
So, if you're passing everything by reference
and you weren'tusing pointers in the first place,
Then your calling code doesn't
need to change at all.
In anycase, whether using references or pointers,
this is the recommended thing to do.
It's not recommendedto rewrite functions to
take unique pointers instead of pointers.
Only the code that dealtwith
creating new widgets or deleting widgets
would need to be changed
to use smart pointers.
All the code in the middle that just uses
widget pointers or references shouldn't need to change.
Then we get to another benefit.
We no longer have to remember to delete this
widget before poppingit off the back.
Popping off a unique pointer
will automatically delete the resource.
In the secondcase, the compiler automatically
stops us from making a potential mistake.
The compiler now forcesus to move into
this local variable last instead of copying into it.
This might seem a bit annoying.
But it actually protects you from the possibility of double
deleting like we had in the raw pointersituation.
You can use the arrow operator on a
new pointer just like you would a normal pointer.
And finally we don't need to do
any of these deletes.
The unique pointers handle
that for us.
Sooverall, the code got
a little bit shorter.
But the main benefit is that we just don't
have to worryabout new's and delete's anymore.
Why burden yourself with that
when the compiler can do it for you?
Andthis is where a lot
of other tutorials might end.
You see some flashy code fixing one
exampleand a specific case
Someone that you don't really know tells you
to use this thingthat you don't really understand.
But maybe you're super vigilant.
And you at least try tolook at
the source code and see how it works.
So you go to definition.
And you see this.
And then you never use
unique pointer.
Standardlibrary implementers have
to write it this way for reasons.
Reasons that unfortunatelyforce
the code to be completely unreadable.
But the main idea is behind unique pointer are
very simple. And you could write it yourself.
So let's do it.
Let's write unique pointer.
We'll start with the class template.
For now justassume that `T` is
a normal non-array non-reference type.
Think an int or a widget.
The real standardunique pointer has
a specialization for arrays.
And it also allows you to specify
a custom deletertype.
But we're just going to keep it simple.
No arrays and just using the built-in delete.
Maybewe can add custom deleters
in a follow-up video.
A unique pointer just wraps a pointer.
So let'sgive it a pointer member.
The main feature of unique pointer
is that it calls delete and it'sdestructor.
By putting delete in the destructor,
we ensure that the pointer is eventually deleted.
Because C++ guarantees that destructors
are called even if there's an exception.
Technically speaking, it's okay
to delete an null pointer
which is going to be our
not-holding-anything value.
But I'm setting us up for
custom deleters in the future.
And a custom deleter might
not support that.
That's why we have
this if check.
Next, we need constructors.
The real unique pointerhas a ton of them.
But you really only need
just a few.
We'll have one to construct from a raw pointerthat
just initializes our pointer to that value.
And a default constructor to
hold a null pointer.
Now, it's common to have a copy constructor and a
copy assignment operator to go along with it
that make copies of
your object.
But for a unique pointer that
doesn't make sense.
If we made a
copy of a unique pointer,
then we'd have two unique pointers
that both think they own thesame object.
And would both try
to delete it.
That would be incorrect.
Unique ownership impliesthat copying
a unique pointer would be a bug.
So in this case, we explicitly delete the
copy constructor and copy assignment operator.
Next let's define functions for either
giving upor changing ownership.
First up is release
which is for giving up ownership.
We've set our internalpointer
to null and then return the old one.
We don't delete the old one.
Giving upownership means that the caller is taking
that responsibility it's their problem now.
Alsonote that this pattern of setting a
value and returning the old one is extremely common.
And itcan be written this
way using standard exchange.
Reset on the other hand swaps
out the thingthat we own.
There's no one else that's taking
that responsibility we still own the old one.
So after we take ownership of the new pointer,
we need to delete the old one.
And once againthis could be
written using standard exchange.
So, release and reset are kind of the building
blocks that we use to change ownership.
But so far, we don't have an easy way to directly transfer
ownership from one unique pointer to another.
That's what the move constructor
and moveassignment operator are for.
These operators are characterized by the fact that
their functionargument is an R value reference.
I'm definitely not going to attempt to explain value
categoriesin the middle of another video.
Suffice it to say that our value
references are typicallytemporaries
or otherwise about
to be destroyed.
Think of a function's return value
or somethingexplicitly cast
to R value using standard move.
The whole purpose of this is to allow you to
stealthe guts of another object before it's destroyed.
In our case, stealing the guts have
another uniquepointer
means asking it to release
ownership of its held pointer.
And then assigning that
toourselves.
Move assignment is similar.
We guard against assigning
to ourselves.
Ask the other thingto release ownership
and then take ownership for ourselves using reset.
We need to use reset here
instead of just assigning the pointer
because we might already
own something
that needs to bedeleted before
we take ownership of something new.
And that's basically it.
We just need to definesome getters
and other convenience functions to
make this usable like a normal pointer.
Operator bool allows us to do if checks
and other boolean-like things on the pointer.
The getfunction just gives out
the underlying pointer
so that people that don't care about
ownership canjust use it.
Operator Arrow allows us to forward
Arrow operations down to the underlying pointer.
Sothat p arrow something will
result in endpointer arrow something.
And finally there's operator
star or the dereference operator if you prefer.
It allows star p on the unique pointer
to end up dereferencing the held pointer.
Zooming out. The whole thing fit
inunder 50 lines of pretty easy code.
And if you ignore blank lines, I
can even sneak in make unique too.
Okay, I'll zoom in on that for a sec but
this isjust icing on the cake.
Just change standard unique
pointer to unique pointer
and standard make unique
to R make unique.
And the whole thing
works as is.
It doesn't matter if an exception is thrown. Ourused
widget function didn't have to change
We don't have to remember
to manually deleteanything.
If we tried to break unique ownership
by copying, the compiler would stop us.
I mean, it's notlike
a great error message.
C++ could definitely use some
improvement on that front.
But it doesstop us.
It forces us to use move in which
case ownership is transferred gracefully.
And we don'thave to loop over the vector and clean up at the end.
All that's just taken care of.
Now of course,smart pointers
are not a silver bullet.
They are but one tool
in your bag.
It's possible that unique
ownership does not fit your problem.
Although maybe shared ownership
and a shared pointer would be abetter fit.
But even then maybe not.
It's possible to accidentally try
to use a move from object.
Andit's possible that one of
your functions tries to keep a reference
that becomes a dangling reference
once the unique pointer goes out of scope.
So using a unique pointer doesn't automatically
protect you or make your code correct.
However, the benefit
of smart pointers is clear.
Smart pointersreduce the
number of bugs that you write.
And unless you have a good reason
not to and thereare some good reasons.
Then you probably should be
using them.
As always thanks for watching.
And thankyou to my patrons and
donors for supporting me.
Don't forget to like, comment and subscribe.
And if youespecially like the video,
please consider becoming a patron on Patreon.
Feel free to make suggestionsof other video
topics you'd like to hear about in the comments below.
And you can also come anddiscuss
programming in my Discord link below.
Anyway thanks for watching.
And see you next time.